[Music]
everyone my name is Johnny Davis I'm a
product manager at Google on a product
called cloud interconnect today we have
four speakers that are going to be
discussing how they integrate with our
recently announced partner interconnect
product tomorrow at 11:40 we'll be doing
a more in-depth session on the specific
internet interconnect products on hybrid
networking so if you're enjoying this
session please join us tomorrow at 11:40
for that session our first speaker today
is Karan Malhotra he is a director of
product management on net bond at AT&T
please welcome
hi welcome and thank you all for taking
some time out to listen to what we have
to talk about and see how networking is
a key component in your cloud strategy
so just one a level set to begin with
right this is nothing new
all of you are aware you know all the
analysts out there I give their reports
and metrics cloud continues to grow the
investment in cloud grows from a
customer and cloud provider perspective
security remains at the top but really
what I wanted to highlight here is over
the last several years the conversation
has really shifted from you know why the
cloud and how to how many clouds are you
connecting to and how do you work
between those clouds and in a hybrid
cloud strategy so if you look across you
know IDC Gartner all the other analysts
and read through all the reports really
you can summarize it across four
variables that you see here right
security and performance are what gets
talked about the most but really
simplicity and cost are key drivers from
a business perspective as you you know
migrate wherever you are in your cloud
journey as you migrate and pivot as
trends change as customer needs change
and so I'm gonna highlight those four
areas across the presentation so I just
want to give quick background on AT&T
network right it's the prime value
that's brought to the table here
obviously a global network we work
through a number of providers we have
more than 200 petabytes of data
streaming through our network each day
right a very large capital investor
about bringing fiber to businesses you
know around the country so now I want to
jump into your options right as you look
to connect to the cloud you have a
variety of options
the Internet's there right it gives you
through some encryption tunnels you can
get a level of security but you're still
susceptible to some of the security
threats such as DDoS also have a level
of performance but you know not
guaranteed right here again susceptible
to the equipment and best effort of the
internet what really chimes in here as
well as again cost and the simplicity
right you can get this set up but you
may have some fixed
commitments and Ben with requirements
that you may not be able to easily
change now taking a step further and if
you build our private connectivity your
performance and security is greatly
increasing right just by getting off of
the internet now again the key here is
cost efficiency and simplicity if you
want to build this out you're gonna have
to over provision right you need to plan
for growth so you don't want to put in a
small bandwidth you want to be able to
add what do you think you might grow and
plan for that so you need a provision
you need redundancy you need to get all
the resources to configure manage get
equipment set up in these locations and
then of course we want to connect in the
region's across the country and across
the globe you now have to kind of
exponentially build towards that so as
AT&T approached this area we really
looked across those four areas and how
can we meet customer needs and demands
based on their business speed and so
what we built out is net bond for cloud
we've pre provisioned redundant 10 gig
circuits to numerous cloud providers
around the world with Google cloud or in
San Jose and Chicago and in Ashburn and
what really what this allows the
customers to do is not have to plan so
far ahead and make commitments to get
this connection and security and
performance and reliability you can work
through us we've done API integration
and use SD enabled architecture and
orchestration on the backend to allow
for seamless provisioning to Google
cloud literally within minutes right so
you don't have to plan this ahead of
time if you're ready to go you log into
the portal and you get started right and
as your growth moves across you can
easily flex you can start at you know 10
megabits per second and move all the way
up into multi gig bandwidth needs again
within minutes right you don't have to
wait put in orders and go through that
process and really tying into the global
AT&T network this really allows any IOT
endpoint any remote office remote worker
regional offices colocation data centers
everything that connects into the
network can traverse and connect your
cloud seamlessly so as a area one at a
high
a little bit is you know similar to
Google's model we approached this base
with the customer in mind and so we
really looked worked across all the
verticals and industries and every size
customer and asked you know what are
your needs how how are you my grading
how are you moving how are you growing
and of course their needs vary right
across the verticals and across
different sized companies but really we
looked at innovation and developing into
the platform and creating features to
allow for the customer to be flexible as
they as they grow so we want to
highlight in management space you know
we have a simple intuitive website where
you can log in and manage and see
reporting set up alerts all that great
stuff but a lot of customers are using
you know custom platform or they manage
their cloud workloads as well as the
network they may have a third party and
so we API enabled all of the service and
user management so we have tens of api's
that allow you to do everything you can
within the portal from a performance
perspective
yes we're off internet and it's inherent
in the plat and the infrastructure but
we also have service level agreement
across four metrics right jitter latency
data delivery and service availability
so we're not just saying we're really
good we back it up we also allow
customers to prioritize traffic right if
you're using you know maybe connections
to backup data at certain intervals you
have video conference calls going over
those same links you know we the
customers were asking us we want to be
able to prioritize this traffic and we
allow you to tag those packets we also
went in and in our architecture we had
from certain verticals such as
healthcare request for we still need
better performance and so we looked at
it and again you know we've heard a lot
about multi cloud over the last couple
days and really customers were asking
I'm moving app data stored here I have
analytics over here my sales SAS
products or somewhere else so what we
did is instead of routing all that
traffic from that peering location back
to the customers network or data center
and then back out to the third cloud we
inherently route all traffic to the
nearest router right so if you have some
workloads in Los Angeles and others up
in the North West and let's say your
data centers in Chicago you don't have
to traverse halfway across the country
in backhoe
just hit the local router and move on
from a security perspective we also got
a lot of customer requests of I want to
add additional layers of security right
if there's any malicious activity in the
cloud how do I protect my network and
vice versa so we allow for customers our
drop in tens of appliances in between
whether it's for performance or security
so firewalls ids/ips when accelerators
anything you really think of we allow
you know one gig 10 gig ports to allow
you to bring in what you need and manage
all that traffic between your network
and the cloud and then again hitting on
customer experience right we really
wanted to make sure it was simple and
seamless and working easily with the
customers need so we we provide a white
glove provisioning treatment essentially
we'll walk you through it right it's
again it's a real simple click through
process you can do it by yourself within
minutes but some customers still not
comfortable or they don't have the
expertise you know what we'll jump in
and help you get everything set up and
up and running so another piece a lot of
customers look at is have a hybrid cloud
use case right I have you know either
some systems that I already have in
local data centers or maybe have lots of
workloads there and one of my great some
but I want to leave some there so how do
we build across that so really
leveraging our colocation partners and
in our own IDC s and as well as our data
centers and using AT&T MPLS network we
can bridge that gap and really provide
from a single provider your end-to-end
connectivity from the hybrid use case or
straight cloud use case really again in
a global standpoint and so one kind of
example I really wanted to highlight
this came up recently there was a large
home automation company they have
thousands of end devices and they were
routing they had their data aggregation
and rules engines to data centers one
was in San Jose one was in Atlanta and
they were using a cloud provider for
storage and analytics and that type of
stuff and so they were not getting the
performance they need it they were using
a mix of private connectivity as well as
internet connectivity
and they had you know some major needs a
big shift in their strategy and they
wanted to move fast so they came to us
said can you do this we need it in three
weeks so with our solution with our
network and with net bond we had
connectivity to those IOT solutions as
well as the cloud providers we went back
to them and said yeah we can get you up
and running today right so obviously we
work at the speed of your business right
as your needs change we can then flex
and pivot accordingly all right so
really to tie this all together you know
going back to the four components right
security right being off internet we
have additional levels of security but
we also again based on your needs we
allow to add additional layers of
security and we continually build within
our network as well we have our own kind
of virtualized functions you can add in
some managed firewall services you can
add in you can add in your own white box
right and spin up be enough says needed
from a performance perspective
great we're SLA backed again allow you
to add more and we continue to look at
our architecture to see how can we make
those improvements and really meet your
needs as your company grows but really
the two things I focus on or simplicity
and cost efficiency right wherever you
are on your cloud journey we can help
step in and get you going today right
you don't need to make a big plan and
architect all these things out just
login set it up start using it you don't
need it the next day
disconnect it right there's no
commitment there's no long-term kind of
things to tie you down let's get started
let's keep moving and let's work at your
speed thank you
thank scream and up next is Bryan Lily
he is the chief product officer of
Equinix thanks Bryan ok I really wish
they make these podiums shorter I don't
know what it is but so I'm going to talk
to you we've each got ten minutes and
I'm going to try and really give you a
snapshot of the work we've been doing
with Google on the partner cloud
interconnect you know we've been working
with Google for for several years now
you know even back to two layer three
peering and and so it's just been a
wonderful relationship and it's come
it's come quite a long way so I'm going
to introduce you to the ECX which is the
Equinix cloud exchange and it really
started as Equinix cloud exchange and
only recently became the fabric this
cloud exchange started as as a way
really to offer efficient connectivity
for customers like Google to multiple
enterprises and you can see the features
are its on-demand its private networking
it's private network connectivity it's
completely software-defined an API
enabled and I'll show you that in a
minute and it's available in 30-plus
metros so we're we're in 52 metros
around the world and Google's with us in
21 well with the launch of fabric which
really is in us interconnecting our data
centers together
we've now extended the reach with Google
to an additional 10 metros so it's 31
altogether and so you can get multiple
multiple connection options to Google
Cloud you can do private Direct Connect
or you can do it over the cloud exchange
fabric you also though can connect to
your own infrastructure so if you're in
multiple sites you actually can connect
to yourself across those metros and and
whether that's for primary dr etc or
finding somebody else within the
ecosystem that you want to connect to
and that's really in a nutshell what
what cloud exchange is so we're the
Google partner interconnect is located
is here you can see the multiple
locations these are the 21
if you overlay where the interconnect
exists and then this the the fabric is
how we've connected our sites together
we're live in in both the US any mayor
will be live in the next few weeks
interconnecting our data centers in Asia
so APEC will go live as you can see it's
dotted because it's it's not general
available yet and then what you'll see
is in q4 we'll be connecting the world
and that's underway right now and this
really to us is a way that our customers
are n customers primarily enterprises
have come and said you know to us as a
partner to Google they've said we want
to reach the Google Cloud and in some
cases it was right in the data center
they were in and we have 10,000
customers in other cases it wasn't where
they were located and this fabric
allowed them to connect seamlessly to it
now in in certain locations and I'll say
it's today it's 8:00 and you can see
hong kong has an asterisk there because
it's coming soon it'll be nine soon
where you're within two milliseconds of
the Google cloud platform sub two
milliseconds implies that if you're
running your workloads at Equinix you
actually can really be connected to the
Google cloud as if it was a part of your
own infrastructure so you get the
benefits and I've personally spoken with
Earths about this is that when you think
about workloads residing and the power
of sort of Google in particular when you
think of analytics you know if you're
running your application for whatever
reason on your premise and that premise
happens to be with us you actually can
have your data resident in Google or
vice versa if you don't want your your
data there you can have your data on on
your premise and actually use the
applications and tools in Google to run
seamlessly over that fabric this is
significant and gives really the best of
both worlds and we've seen several
companies organizations customer
take advantage of these connectivity
options now for the other there's so I
said there are 21 locations specifically
for the other 12 you're still within in
some cases 5 10 15 20 milliseconds but
this is actually sub 2 milliseconds now
what we've spent a lot of time on is a
you know the developer community so I
don't know how many in the audience are
developers but we've we've really wanted
to API enable the entire platform and
we're seeing significant uptake so we
just launched recently this is our third
iteration of the developer portal so if
you go to developer Equinix com you can
have access to the developer experience
you can subscribe to the API as you can
see them all the contracts are there and
the documentation are there and to give
you an example these are some of the
api's that are available now cloud
exchange is by far the most leveraged
api's that we have and what we're seeing
now is is I don't again I don't know if
there's if it's a combination of
customers or partners in here but if
you're a partner you can actually embed
these api's into your offer and we're
starting to see some we just did a
webinar on this two weeks ago with
infinite at who has included and
embedded these api's into their offer
and it's again in a hybrid cloud a
hybrid multi cloud and if I if I go back
for one second there's one note on here
that just got added and I want to I
really want to highlight this we use
today we use kubernetes to orchestrate
our our docker environment with this gke
on-prem you actually can run that on
Prem kubernetes environment kubernetes
engine in your cage in your deployment
and use that to orchestrate across
multiple clouds and so we are just now
with that announced
we're just now looking at how do we
extend our existing kubernetes
deployment and actually use that to to
orchestrate our workloads both on Prem
and across in in Google where we run
today a number of workloads in
particular in you know if you think
about a data center a data center is a
big thing and it's full of things and so
we stream data out of our data centers
and it's it's a very very large IOT use
case and we're using Google and the
analytics in Google to run that
environment and and we expect to run to
run more now that we have this this new
solution so we're pretty happy about
that announcement so if I'd go back to
the api's these api's are available
today you can configure them in minutes
it's an on-demand platform and I think
like you just heard karoon say you know
in this sort of and I don't have today a
demonstration to show you however Paul
Masson Paul if you could raise your hand
Paul's our lead solution architect on
this he did a session in the in the
floor where he demonstrated in about 90
seconds he set up a connection to us
East 4 which is in Ashburn and and in in
about like it like I said about 90
seconds set up the connection
transferred eight gigs of data in
approximately 30 seconds 20 to 20 to 30
seconds and he can demonstrate that
again for you if you want to swing by so
this is all SCN enabled and as Corinne
said you can set this up for minutes
days hours weeks etc it's a very very
nice way to to manage your connections
to the cloud and so we have several use
cases these are just a couple we have
today over a hundred and thirty
connections to through the Google
partner cloud interconnect we have in
some cases we have a very large retail
provider that is using cloud exchange to
route between Google cloud environments
for for redundancies
purposes and this is to achieve their
SLA we have another we have another
customer who wanted to actually move
data and workloads out of another CSP
over to Google and Google actually
brought us this lead and asked us if we
could help them solve this problem and
we actually moved those workloads and
then we have one ourself that I've
already mentioned which is how we're
using it to run our own IOT analytics
which really leads us to PUA prediction
which we're getting pretty good at and
so I would just say visit our website
there's one URL that's not on here I
would strongly recommend it's free and
it's really good it's called IO a KB in
a connection oriented architecture
knowledgebase IO a KB com you can log in
there and there's free blueprints on how
to our custom build your own you know
basically network diagrams for how to
build a hybrid multi cloud and with
Google prominently in there so I think
I'm out of time I'm out of my ten
minutes thank you thanks a lot Brian and
next up is Matt Simpson VP of cloud
product at Becca port thank you everyone
hello San Francisco how refreshing it is
to meet everyone and be here rather than
I guess in Vegas I love Vegas but I'm
sure everyone in this room has been to
many times this year with certain events
so mega port so there's some
commonalities with some of these
presentations with both AT&T and Equinix
and that is giving your customers choice
in getting to Google and I guess with
GCI it's and the partners that we're
presenting here is the extending the
reach of Google and bringing Google to
to you today I'm going to talk about me
report so mega port is a global
software-defined Network and we're in
the business of interconnecting data
centers one of the biggest problems and
one of the the biggest questions that we
do get from customer
is I'm in one particular data center but
I'm looking to access certain services
from another on-ramp location how am I
going to get my connections and my
direct access between those two parties
so what we've done over the last few
years is built a layer 2 network across
221 data centers and where data center
agnostic so we work work between players
like edge connects digital reality we're
in equity X we're also an interruption
in Europe and and what that brings is a
really rich ecosystem of services and
that that's really important when you're
looking to access GCP there's 4,000
datacenters out there so we're still are
growing this quarter alone we built into
21 data centers so we're continuing to
build that network out globally so the
key differentiator between us and say a
traditional network is we've aligned our
business model similar to cloud there's
no locking contracts you can scale on
demand similar to it the other partners
that presented and it's it's rapid it's
fast within a few minutes you'll be able
to connect to GCP and today I'm actually
prey to the demo guys I'm going to do a
bit of a quick demo for you as well and
showcase the portal and and give you a
scenario of a particular customer use
case going from one cloud provider to
GCP so I just want to highlight our
network and the reach that we have so
Google you know has an extensive
backbone I think there's a couple of
hundred points of presence and
congratulations on the recent
announcement I think they're laying a
subsidy cable between Virginia and and
Belgium but beyond that there's our
network as well so across that you can
scale your bandwidth and you can connect
from any of those data centers those 221
but I really also want to highlight the
cloud on-ramps as well so there's a
hundred and six cloud on-ramps that
of interconnected with and it's really
important we're talking about
multi-cloud here and cut and you as a
customer looking to get direct access to
the best digital technology so that you
can remain agile and that you can remain
competitive here's our colorful dots a
great map just to highlight our points
of presence and where we've
interconnected with GCI
so we are available across 10 cities in
20 locations and you can interconnect at
any of those locations today they're all
live I've also highlighted direct
peering so today is all about getting
asset direct access to your V pcs but if
you're looking to access G suite or some
of those public resources then you can
also interconnect via the direct peering
option there too so how do we how do we
deliver the service and again I really
want to highlight multi-cloud here
because I know some of you in the room
are probably using other cloud providers
and other technology and how do you
actually get access to GCP today and so
on the left hand side if we go from left
to right we're looking at our
traditional layer 2 service so a
customer would essentially establish a 1
gig or a 10 gig port in any of our data
center locations via the portal once
they cross connect and provision that
interface the virtual cross connections
or the VLANs to GCP can be stood up in
less than a few minutes and really what
we're trying to showcase here is that
ability if you're using another cloud
provider you can actually start using
GCP today and I guess on the bottom here
we've got mega port cloud router and
I'll go into that in a little bit I
really want to focus on that in a minute
so there's a couple of sa SLA options
that that you have with Google to get
the four nines of availability what that
looks like on this side is two ports
interconnected from two different data
centers
corresponding with four VLANs on the GCI
side you're looking at establishing four
cloud routers with four VLAN attachments
the VX is again is where the flexibility
of the service interacts and you can on
our side establish from one megabit
right up to ten gigabits and you can
change that on the fly so this year we
actually released a new product over the
last few years our customers were coming
to us and saying wouldn't it be great if
I could localize my traffic if I was
expanding my business say I'm in in Oz
and I'm looking to tap into North
America but I'm not really interested in
establishing space power physical
Network routers I really I was born in
the cloud and I'm looking to get access
to GCP but I'm not looking to invest in
in some of that networking
infrastructure and this is mega port
cloud router it's a private light layer
three capability which allows cloud to
cloud networking and also enables
localized traffic again I'll point out
106 cloud on-ramps will continue to
expand with Google and that number will
grow and just show showcasing that
example here so we have a customer in LA
they might be media and entertainment
they've got some on-premise
infrastructure say in the disability
facility in LA they're looking to
establish a 10 gig port in LA and
they're connecting traditionally with a
VLAN to GCP and AWS and on the right
hand side they're looking to expand on
the East Coast but they're not looking
to invest in the infrastructure there so
what they can do is establish a mega
port cloud router within a couple of
minutes they could start at 100 Meg if
they wanted to and then they could
interconnect from AWS to GCP within
minutes and start passing traffic over
our layer to network within a couple of
hours
so we're gonna flip over I'm gonna no
one use the Wi-Fi I'm kidding
and I'm going to jump into the portal
is everyone sort of familiar with GCI
establishing it via the Google console
just raise your hands
there's a couple not too many so the
first step is you would go into the
Google console you go over to your
hamburger and you'd scroll down into
networking and you would select hybrid
connectivity so there we go we got
hybrid connectivity and you would select
into connect and then you've got two
options dedicated interconnect so if
you're in the same facility as Google
then great you could do dedicated and
you'll you'll get your own 10 gig port
then you have the GCI partner option
what I've done just to save a little bit
of time because I know that there's a
lot of partners presenting today I've
pre-loaded one already and what I've
done here is established two cloud
routers with two veal and interconnects
so on the right I've got my two VLAN er
interconnects and sorry for my Aussie
slang I've pulled it true blue VLAN one
with true blue VLAN two against two
cloud routers and these are the Google
cloud routers which is this is a router
mate number one and this is a router
mate number two so I'm going to flip
over to the portal the first step is you
would lock in it's it's web-based so
mega port al or portal mega port com
anyone can trial this out you can see
pricing you can also see all of the
locations that GCP that we have enabled
today as well so it's it's like buying a
pair of Nike shoes as I say you go from
left to right and you check it out and
you deploy so the first step is I would
establish an MCR as I call it mega port
cloud router
and you've got the two options again
create mega port which is going to be if
you want to establish a 10 gig port on
the a side and then the Z side is the
Google I guess location
so here I've already pre-loaded in MCR
if it takes a couple of minutes just to
deploy that I've got my connection in
Ashburn in AWS already connected and
what I'm going to do here
is just change this and preload and
configure my a end so I'll click on to
the VLAN one configure BGP pop in my a s
number which is going to be my MC our a
s and then I'm just going to copy the
local router IP and enter that into the
IP address space there establish bgp on
the a end alright
Google's is the local IP is already
pre-loaded for me again similar to the
other partners we've done an API
integration and was simplified and brew
some of that complexity
I will then copy my cloud router prefix
and I'm going to enter that in as well
quick okay
I'm just gonna remove that one and apply
but that's going to do is going to push
an API call through right through to the
cloud router and enable that connection
so it does take a couple of minutes so
just to speed up a bit of the time you
will see that rocket spinning around I'm
probably just going to run straight
through but just want to showcase the
ecosystem as well so with with GCP
you're looking at accessing some of the
digital technology but also in here you
can access some of our MSP partners
we've got network service providers so
beyond the data centers that we're in
you can actually interconnect with and
do last-mile with some of those partners
as well and again there's a whole
marketplace full of different service
providers and that again is adding a lot
of value to you for your solutions I'm
looking at wrapping up because I'm
running out of time so we'll flip back
flip back to the slides if if you might
this is EJ oh yes awesome
so just recap we've got a la we've got
our physical port we don't have to do
that if we don't want to we've got a
virtual cross connection connecting to
our mega port cloud router which is our
virtual lies layer 3 capability and then
we have virtual cross connections
between AWS and GCP we've just popped in
our marketplace there if you're looking
to access say Rackspace or Newt annex we
do have a booth here as well there's a
lot of detail around MCR
and we've got our team in the room as
well so if any questions again thanks
very much for having us and on to
Verizon
so next up next up ghazan Simon is a
distinguished engineer at Verizon on
cloud thank you so much Kazan where I
focus on networking solution in general
and for the last couple of years been
focusing on cloud communication I'm here
to talk to you about Verizon secure
cloud interconnect which is Verizon
solution to connect our customer to that
cloud partner in general and to Google
cloud in particular however before I
start talking about SDI per se I would
like to take a minute or so to position
SDI within Verizon portfolio it doesn't
matter today whether you're working on
the network whether you're writing code
for Google you're doing dev up we are
all working with the ultimate goal of
developing and supporting the
application that runs the business in
that regard Verizon has developed a
large portfolio of services that is
intended to help our customer into the
enablement of that application whether
it's on the networking level with our
private IP network or MPLS our 4G 5g
wireless network on the connectivity
level with secure cloud interconnect
itself or our Sdn services in the
virtualization layer where a large
number of network functionality is being
virtualized the orchestration layers
that manage these different virtual
instances and help with the migration
toward the software-defined network at
the application layer with our api's and
different tools that manage the
application or the security layer that
encompasses all these services we have a
full digital supply chain that is
intended to help you with out your
application so secure cloud interconnect
is one component of this portfolio but
it work in conjunction with other number
of services so why should you care about
secure cloud and connect and why should
you consider it you probably heard about
all the stuff already from the previous
presenters but from our perspective we
always talk to our customer trying to
understand how their businesses is
shifting and consequently how that
impact their need for the network so
what they told us
years ago is done hours a day where
fringe applications are deployed into
the cloud or where a couple of Engineers
are trying to toy with some application
into the cloud our customer who are
planning and are today deploying
critical application was very sensitive
data so it's it's not a surprise that at
the top of that list they have
securities I wanted networks that
provide the security that's required and
necessary to deploy those application
more interestingly so they told us that
the network was that environment today
is becoming much more flexible and much
more dynamic they need you know things
are changing at a much faster rate than
what it used in the past so they don't
want to have to wait for five or few
months for a network to be established
they don't want to be cornered with the
contract for two or three years and they
don't want to have that traffic police
for a random port spiel they want their
network as well to be as dynamic and as
flexible as they can what they are doing
in the cloud now they are deploying a
particular application so they expect
the network to provide performance that
is predictable that they can rely on to
deploy and support those application and
manage abilities as well very critical
for them so they can understand where
the problem is in the network where
there are issues and how they can fix
those very quickly and as nobody have
more money than usual they want all this
feature with allowing them at the same
time to save on that cost so that's what
we try to achieve with sei and how did
we do that so we started with what we
have Verizon has a very large private IP
network that provide the security that
the customer is looking for provides the
performances was our SLA and class of
services and provide the manageability
what was missing is the connectivity to
the cloud operators so in this
particular case we shown the example
with Google so what we did we went to
the different location where Google has
deployed peering location and we
deployed our own physical router so we
have two lauter from Verizon there are
two router from Google we establish a
pair of 10 Giga and I so like this we
are providing it at London connection
between our network and Google
facilities so when a network and ours
today is want to connect to Google we
start by creating an SDI for
our router we connect it to their
private IP VPN network on one side and
through an API that we have with Google
we establish connection towards their
Google project it's all software driven
it takes few minutes for the whole
connection to be up and running what we
did too is that we extended that
connectivity to our wireless network a
large number of our customers are
expanding into the wireless domain
either because they are you know
deploying more and more IOT driven
application maybe they are using that
wireless network as a backup to the
while--and network we have gateways
today that connect the wireless network
to the wildin network so when they have
devices on the wireless network they can
now gain the same connectivity get
access to the same application to the
same set of data as a while--and
counterpart we also moved away a little
from the legacy elect environment or
legacy Lac model where you have to order
access and port and pay a monthly
recurring charges with sei we are
adopting the same model as the cloud
operators and have you pay for the
resources you used which in this
particular case is the amount of traffic
that goes through the port so you're not
a more constrained by a poor speed you
can burst up and down based on the need
of your application now we took that
design and we replicated into many
locations across the globe this is
showing the connection we have with
Google only so for those of you are
familiar with Google operation you know
that Google offer different mode of
peelings Verizon has been a partner with
Google on the carrier peering option for
many years now and then as Google has
introduced that part and interconnect we
are deploying separate set of an and I
to support that peering option as well
you can see from the map here that in
every region we have two or more
clearing location providing you that way
with a geographical diversity to access
your Google facilities in the previous
slide I mentioned that SDI is usage
based so what you can do right now is go
and deploy your SDI port at any one of
these locations there is no fixed cost
associated with sei you are paying for
the amount of traffic that goes through
the port so you have the flexibility to
deploy your SDI connection at many
location gain advantage of diversity and
proximity to your user
now a CI like many of these services
they're to Verizon support we have a GUI
based portal for managing and supporting
the application but we've been talking
about speed flexibility and
software-defined network and you've seen
it from the other provided as well
Verizon is working on API for all the
new services and sei is one of those
services that's benefiting from that
development so today we have a group of
sei Command that are available for you
and we're working on more for 2018-19
with the sei now you can script the
behavior that you expect from the
network if you for example working with
us on management tool for your
application and you determined that your
application needs I have changed or
evolved you can now automate the change
of the network to accommodate the
changes that are happening at your
application layer now to conclude my
presentation I'm gonna go through a
quick example of a customer we're
working with today it's a large retail
customer that has you know thousands of
store across the u.s. they want to
decommission their data center and move
that application to the cloud and for
that they decided to partner with Google
to host their application they reach out
to us to provide the connectivity
between their Google facilities and
their store and for that we deployed to
a CI port one in San Jose a and one in
Chicago providing them like this with
the diversity that they need to connect
to Google we extended that connection as
well to that distribution fleet so our
wireless network
one of the application that are trying
to start up wins is to track every
transaction on their in their stores so
they can know the amount invented in
each one of these stores and as a result
they can direct the distribution fleet
to the adequate store to ensure that the
store are always adequately stacked I
talked about you know sei working with
conjunction with other services so in
this particular case we are hosting for
them to virtual firewall
one was each of the sei port which will
provide them with an additional layer of
security and allow them to control
better the traffic that's going in and
out of their corporate network finally
we're working with them on a number of
application tools to manage the
performance of that application whether
into Google environment into our network
the wireless network or their store so
they can quickly determine if there are
changes or impact on the performance and
need to do to him - you know remedy to
this and ensure that they have the
performs they are looking for further
application so it's this bundling of all
these services is that digital supply
chain that Verizon is offering to our
customer you know occasionally
partnership with Google so to help you
with your application enable Minh
[Music]